[Musique]
bonjour geneviève morel bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes psychanalyste à paris et à lille
ancien mathématicienne vous avez
travaillé sur des sujets aussi
différents que le terrorisme la prison
l'ambiguïté sexuelle et vous allez nous
éclairer aujourd'hui sur des effets du
confinement sur la pratique analytique
ce que vous avez observé ce que vous
avez mises en place est-ce que vous avez
compris d'abord est-ce que des thérapies
à distance vous en avez déjà pratiqués
avant la crise sanitaire oui en fait il
se trouve que des personnes que j'avais
suivi pendant un certain temps chez moi
était parti à l'étranger après et que
donc j'ai continué à les suivre par
téléphone ou par sky avant le
confinement
comme j'observais beaucoup ce qui se
passait en italie je me disais ça va
nous tomber dessus donc j'ai commencé à
en parler à mes analyses en personne qui
venait me voir leur disant que peut-être
on serait obligé de passer à une autre
forme de pratique c'est ce qui s'est
passé puisque arrive le 17 mars date du
confinement total du pays comment ça se
passe à ce moment là dans votre pratique
que décidez-vous à aucun moment
interrompre le lien n'a été envisagée
alors pas par moi en tout cas disons
'peut-être par certains pas recette
certaines personnes mais en fait moi je
les pose est comme au fond puisque ça ça
peut continuer n'y aucune raison de
l'arrêté et même quand y'en a qui m'ont
dit ah ben moi je préfère revenir quand
ce sera terminé je leur ai dit écoutez à
ce moment là si je considère ça comme
une interruption puisque le lien il
qu'on pourrait continuer donc il ya pas
de réseau voilà est en fait de fait
quasiment presque tout le monde a
continué alors il raconte les doutes
concrètement les choses vous à des ans
mis en place pour ceux qui étaient
allongés des séances par téléphone ceux
qui sont allongés effectivement ils
peuvent l'appeler et puis ce que j'ai en
face à face puisque j'en ai un certain
nombre qui sont en face à face soit que
ce soit des entretiens préliminaires sur
soi des personnes que je vois de toute
façon en face à face eh bien je leur ai
proposé skype pour facetime enfin un
moyen comme ça j'ai donc c'est vous qui
contacter les patients parce que c'est
c'est remettre en cause un certain
nombre d'habitudes du helmand oui bien
sûr ça cause des rituels ça en est
d'autres en place s'il voulait donc moi
ce que j'ai dit c'est que ils avaient
leur rendez vous voilà et donc il devait
m'envoyer un sms quand il était je leur
disais quand vous êtes dans la salles
d'attentes pour ça les faisait beaucoup
rire genre quand vous êtes dans les
salles d'attentes m'envoyer un sms salle
d'attenté virtuelle dont virtuel et puis
moi je moi je leur répondais tout de
suite par sms je vous dire que j'avais
bien reçu et que je leur dirai quand je
serai disponible et après moi je leur
disais vous pouvez m'appeler et à ce
moment-là il m'appelait voilà c'était
comme ça que ça se passe est salée
déroutait vos patients ou pas parce que
c'est vrai que freud en a beaucoup parlé
ce rituel normalement c'est le patient
qui vient chez l'analyste il attend il
prépare son rendez-vous il s'allonge ou
pas il est en tête à tête et puis à la
fin de la séance il paye alors tout ça
qui vole en éclats ça peut être alors la
danse dakhla d'abord il faut peut-être
remettre les choses en place freud il
était pas si ritualiste que ça par
exemple il considère qu' avec eux deux
deux règles fondamentales de la
psychanalyse qui est l association libre
c'est-à-dire dire sweet tooth qui vous
vient à l'esprit sans censurer parce que
vous trouvez ça imbéciles ou stupides ou
pas jolie ou je sais pas quoi et puis de
venir aux séances en effet de les payer
aussi voilà donc ça c'est les deux les
deux conditions fondamentales
par exemple tout le monde pense que le
divan à une vision de la psychanalyse
avec un divan recouvert si possible un
cachemire enfin moi tout le monde a vu
le divan de frey
mais en fait le divan a été choisi par
freud il le dit hein parce qu'il
supportait pas de qu'on le regarde toute
la journée donc c'était quand même il
pose sa quand jose à ses personnels bon
donc si vous laissez pas non plus posée
par lui comme une règle fondamentale par
exemple on sait que faire un quasi
psychanalytique hongrois que ses élèves
hongrois donc venez le voir pendant les
vacances et que en fait il faisait des
séances d'analysé avec freud en marchant
dans la montagne pendant les vacances je
faisais des marches ensemble ils se
parlent est donc au fond si vous voulez
je crois qu'il faut pas être trop rigide
sur le sur ces rituels parce qu'il faut
pas oublier qu'au fond la psychanalyse
c'est effectivement que vous venez de le
dire très justement un dispositif de
parole dans lequel il ya 2 deux
personnes une qui a une position
d'analyste et l'autre une position d'
analyse en est la position d'analyste ça
veut dire qu'on est on est dans une
certaine inertie quand même qui permet à
l'autre de dire qu'on réagit pas au
quart de tour et c'est en principe qui
permet à l'autre de vous envelopper de
ses fantasmes et de pouvoir en parler de
ce fait est de pouvoir déconstruire ces
symptômes et puis de l'autre côté
quelqu'un qui applique la règle de
l'association libre c'est quelque chose
qui est de l'ordre de la parole mais
très concrètement au téléphone par
exemple est-ce que ça rend pas les six
danses plus pesant alors voilà
l'analyste que vous êtes a dû intervenir
plus c'est vrai que par exemple le
silence de l'analyste dans une pièce où
vous êtes bon va vous savez qu'il est là
les besoins de voir tourner pour savoir
au téléphone
si vous dit absolument rien la personne
elle peut tomber dans une sorte de trou
ce qui fait qu effectivement mois de
temps en temps je disais un mot 2 pour
casser ce jeu sinon la personne vous dit
allô allô d'une façon un peu angoissé
voyez quand on n'a pas forcément à payer
à la fin d'une séance à ce que le coût
de la séance est le même alors moi j'ai
pratiqué le même coup puisque je
considérais que c'était des séances
d'analysé que c'était pas des deux mi
séance ou des semblants de séances
étaient des vrais séance
donc en fait ce qui me payer par chèque
qui m'ont payé par virement et puis ceux
qui ne paient en espèces ils me les ont
amenés à la fin alors effectivement
c'est vrai que ça faisait parfois des
sommes plus importantes et qu' ils
étaient impressionnés par l'argent qui
me donnait plus peut-être que quand il
le donne et toutes les semaines mais
pour vous au fond ça n'a pas
fondamentalement changé ni l'écoutent
analytique ni le transfert du patient
sur son analyste non mais il ya eu des
cas compliqués si vous voulez lesquelles
par exemple les u11 j'ai eu quelqu'un
qui a fait une sorte de décompensation
mélancolique qui avait déjà fait mais
qui au moment du confinement si vous
voulez d'un seul coup quand il sortait
dans la rue il pouvait plus parler aux
commerçants ses points de repères
habituels étaient tombés quoi et il
voulait absolument se faire hospitaliser
lève envie de se jeter par la fenêtre et
s'est donc c'était une situation très
inquiétante il voulait venir chez moi et
moi je voulais pas qu'ils viennent parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui est un peu
fragile par ailleurs physiquement et
donc bon ben j'ai dû vraiment beaucoup
le soutenir voyez parler beaucoup plus
avec lui tu sers à plusieurs données oui
pour lui redonner parce qu'au fond moi
je faisais partie de ces personnes qui
venaient voir et qui scandaient ça se
met à l'envoyer donc il fallait même là
il y avait quelque chose où il fallait
peut-être en rajouter un petit peu alors
décrivez-nous d'après votre clinique
pendant ce confinement ce que ce
confinement a fait sur les gens sur vos
patients et bien moi j'ai été frappé par
le fait que certaines personnes étaient
très très contente du confinement très
heureuse du confinement
soulagé oui soulager alors certes
soulagé pour différentes raisons par
exemple j'ai remarqué ça chez des
personnes qui d'habitude ça qui
d'habitude qui au moment où démarrait le
confinement était au chômage ou dans des
situations compliquées socialement et
ces personnes d'un seul coup se trouvait
à niveler haut comme les a traités comme
les autres puisque tout le monde était
au chômage autre cas de soulagement et
ça c'est du tout ce que j'ai pu
découvrir au fond par exemple quelqu'un
m'a dit alors celle des personnes qui
souvent des professions d'écriture vous
voyez par exemple je pense scénariste
écrivain des personnes comme ça qu'il
travaille beaucoup à la maison il y en a
une d'entre elle qui m'a dit qu'elle
était hyper soulager beaucoup moins
angoissé que d'habitude que lisait
d'ailleurs ml dickinson parce que
c'était quelqu'un qui s'était auto
confiné volontairement toute sa vie est
en fait elle m'a dit mais en fait moi je
suis une confiné et à ne jamais pu
formuler sa avant comme ça je suis une
conf il est c'est-à-dire au fond moi je
suis très heureuse d'être confiné parce
que personne n'est là sur mon dos à me
dire mais pourquoi tu sors pas pourquoi
tu vas pas voir machin etc etc après des
personnes qui allaient mal puisque vous
l'avez demandé ça il y avait les
personnes qui ont été mises au chômage
partiel qui que ça a beaucoup pour moi
c'est souvent parce que bon on voit le
chômage partiel comme quelque chose qui
au fond avantage les gens puisqu'ils
touchent de l'argent vient le temps il
ya l'idée de chômage partiel on enlève
au travail on considère que secondaire
dans l'entreprise voilà donc il y avait
cette idée qu'il n'était pas un disque
sable voiliers et une angoisse aussi
d'être viré après voyez donc ces
personnes là était assez angoissé et le
masque qu'est-ce qu'il a changé le
masque à la pratique analytique je
trouve ça désagréable de voir les autres
avec un masque toute la journée c'est
quand même difficile pour moi
et ça a donné lieu aussi à des choses
assez intéressantes quoi parce qu'on on
pense toujours finalement que le regard
et la essentielle d'un visage ça vient
un peu aussi la religion l'idée de l'âme
enfin voyez ça s'est passé comme les
yeux
et en fait donc avec le masque on voit
les yeux et donc j'ai il se trouve que
j'ai vu des personnes j'ai rencontré des
personnes uniquement masqué qui
commençait dès
les commencer une analyse avec moi après
le confinement que j'ai rencontré masqué
et après il se trouve que je les ai vus
sans masque en vidéo parce qu'elle ne
pouvait pas se déplacer faucher plus ce
qui se passait enfin tout est donc j'ai
été extrêmement surprise au fond je
m'étais fait une image de ces personnes
qui étaient totalement fausses oui bah
oui oui par exemple je pense à à une
jeune fille qui voulait commencer une
transition et qui s'étaient présentés
vraiment avec une physique une
transition sexuelle les transitions
sexuelle et donc qui était s'était
présentée avec un physique très comment
dire des habits un peu vague informe et
sert à une démarche tout ça est en fait
quand elle s'est démasqué j'ai vu bon
une ravissante jeune fille et c'était
vraiment jeu du coup je comprenais mieux
son angoisse soyez son
son angoisse du fait que ses parents
n'acceptent pas tout ça parce qu'on l'a
renvoyé toujours à cette image que elle
même ne pouvait pas assumer quoi vous
avez de nouveaux patients qui viennent
depuis la crise sanitaire quand le réel
a été aussi stupéfiant quand une crise
comme ça dépasse complètement la fiction
est ce que ça crée des malades
psychiques qui fait qu'on n'a pas
forcément pensé à l'analyse et puis il
arrive déjà pendant le confinement j'ai
eu des nouvelles demandes et cet été
chose qui ne m'arriverait jamais j'ai eu
des appels au mois d'août en septembre
en général sous l'ailé personne
d'habitude appelle plutôt à la toussaint
après la rentrée
et après avoir payé leurs impôts enfin
voyez à ce moment là on pense il ya une
période comme ça de grâce après les
grandes vacances normalement hélas ça
n'a pas du tout eu lieu c'est à dire au
contraire il ya eu beaucoup de personnes
qui avaient des malaises mais qu'il ne
relaie pas ou qu vide c'étaient d'autres
mais moi je pense aussi que pendant le
confinement c'est quelque chose qui m'a
frappé les personnes étaient renvoyés
aussi des choses très très intime donc
peut-être que moi je le voyais sur mes
analyses en noir exemple l'idée beaucoup
de rêves sur des maisons d'enfance alors
qu'il n'était pas du tout dans leur
maison d'enfance mais comme si le fait
d'être enfermé à la maison ça les
renvoyer à quelque chose voiliers du
passé finement a permis de rapprocher de
nous rapprocher plus vite de no1
confiant pour certains oui visiblement
et donc je pense que les personnes qui
sont venues là elle me disait pas je
viens par ce que je vois c'est que tu
confies non c'était pas du tout ça c'est
j'ai envie de faire un travail sur moi
même où j'ai passé quelque chose s'est
déclenchée qu'avez vous appris de ce
moment là dans un dans un temps où on se
dit que déconfinement peut-être partiel
pourront se reproduire
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
éviter des erreurs sur quoi on peut
s'appuyer pour la suite pour l'analyste
que vous êtes je pense qu'il faut
effectivement penser la psychanalyse en
dehors de ces rituels par exemple il ya
souvent un refus l'image chez les
psychanalystes et donc certains ont
accepté de téléphone n'est pas la vidéo
enfin vous voyez il y avait des
querelles comme ça et je pense qu' il
faudrait passer au delà de ça à
comprendre que justement c'est pas une
question c'est pas ça vraiment le
problème voilà donc je pense que il y
avait de l'importance du lien
l'importance du lien analytique qui
était quelque chose qui tenait à ce
moment là était quelque chose de très
important et je pense que ça c'est le
son pour la presse aussi dernière
question il ya des centres qui ont été
fermés pendant le confinement je pense à
des centres médico psychologiques les
cmp ça c'est une erreur de l'avoir fait
est-ce qu'il faut essayer de maintenir
plus de liens
moi je pense que c'est au delà il ya des
cabinets privés bah oui mais il était
tout à fait possible dans ccm pp clp de
d'organiser des consultations à distance
et beaucoup de services ne l'ont pas
fait pour des raisons idéologiques qui
était justement l'idée par exemple j'ai
entendu chez certains de mes passions
qui travaillent dans des centres comme
ça qui me disait que on préférait les
renvoyer à la maison alors qu'eux mêmes
avaient proposé de continuer au
téléphone et en vidéo avec les années
les passions qui voyait dans ces centres
et on leur disait non parce qu'il faut
il faut aller au contact et cette
expression de aller au contact un moment
d'épidémie elle ridicule qu est-ce qu on
se le dise aller au contact c'est
justement ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
donc il faut bien inventer une autre
sorte de lien le contact physique quand
il ya une épidémie donc là il y avait
une sorte de haut des prisonniers du
langage je pense il s'agit pas de poser
les choses ont tout ou rien envoyé on
peut tout à fait organiser même dans le
service public des rendez vous sous
d'autres formes merci beaucoup merci
geneviève morel merci beaucoup
[Musique]